FRANCISCO HEADQUARTERS AND WHY.
BUT FIRST, WHO HAS THE BAD
CANDIDATES NOW?
THAT'S THE FOCUS OF TONIGHT'S
ANGLE.
FOR MONTHS THE REGIME MEDIA
WORKED HARD TO BUILD THE
NARRATIVE THAT THE GOP HAD LOST
ITS MOJO THAT THEY HAD BLOWN AN
HISTORIC MIDTERM OPPORTUNITY ALL
BECAUSE THEIR PRIMARY WINNERS
WERE JUST TERRIBLE.
>> YOU DO HAVE REPUBLICANS
NOMINATING, SHALL WE SAY, FLAWED
CANDIDATES.
>> HERSCHEL WALKER IN GEORGIA,
JD VANCE IN OHIO.
DR. OZ IN PENNSYLVANIA.
>> WHAT LOOKED LIKE A WHINEOUT
FOR DEMOCRATS IN THE FALL IS
MAYBE NOT GOING TO BE SO BAD
BECAUSE OF THE CANDIDATES
REPUBLICANS ARE NOMINATING.
>> WALKER CAN LOSE, OZ CAN LOSE,
JOHNSON CAN LOSE.
THEY'RE BAD CANDIDATES.
>> Laura: SO SMUG AND SO WRONG.
LIBERAL SUPER PACKS EVEN HELPED
BOOST THE SO-CALLED ELECTION
DENIER REPUBLICANS IN THE
PRIMARIES WITH THE THOUGHT THAT
THEY WOULD BE EASIER TO DEFEAT
IN THE GENERAL ELECTIONS.
EVEN OUR OWN SENATE MINORITY
LEADER JOINED THE PIG PILE
AGAINST HIS OWN PARTY TRYING TO
TAMP DOWN HIS PARTY'S
EXPECTATIONS BY BLAMING THE
POPULOUS, THE MAGA FOLKS.
>> THERE'S PROBABLY A GREATER
LIKELIHOOD THE HOUSE FLIPS THAN
THE SENATE.
SENATE RACES ARE JUST DIFFERENT,
THEY'RE STATE WIDE.
CANDIDATE QUALITY HAS A LOT TO
DO WITH THE OUTCOME.
>> Laura: HE'S A BARREL OF
LAUGHS, ISN'T HE?
JUST ASTHMA CONDITIONAL WAS
WRONG ABOUT VOTING FOR BIDEN'S
SO-CALL INFRASTRUCTURE BILL, HE
WAS WRONG TO IMPLY THAT
REPUBLICANS JUST CHOSE LOUSY
CANDIDATES.
NOW WE ALL KNOW THE GOP
ESTABLISHMENT HAS BEEN EXPOSED
FOR THEIR MISTAKES ON THINGS
LIKE CHINA TRADE AND THESE
ENDLESS WARS.
AND I THINK IT KIND OF MAKES
THEM NERVOUS WHEN NEW FACES
APPEAR ON THE SCENE WHO JUST
AREN'T BEHOLDENED TO THE OLD
GUARD AND WHO AREN'T AFRAID OF
THEM, AFRAID TO CHALLENGE THEM
EVEN.
THEY HATED TRUMP FOR THE SAME
REASON.
THANK GOD WE HAVE A SYSTEM WHERE
THE PEOPLE, NOT WASHINGTON
DINOSAURS GET TO CHOOSE WHO BEST
TO REPRESENT THEM EVERY ELECTION
CYCLE.
BUT IF WE'RE TALKING WEAK
CANDIDATES AND WE ARE TALKING
WEAK CANDIDATES, THE PARTY THAT
HAS THEM IN SPADES IS THE
DEMOCRAT PARTY.
I MEAN, JB PRITZKER IN ILLINOIS?
PLEASE.
WHO IN HIS RIGHT MIND BELIEVES
HE SHOULD WIN REELECTION.
WHAT HAS HE ACTUALLY DONE TO THE
STATE OTHER THAN PRESIDE OVER A
HUGE POPULATION LOSS.
OTHER THAN, YOU KNOW, FURTHER
WRECKING EDUCATION IN THE STATE
BY ORDERING SCHOOLS TO STAY
CLOSED THROUGHOUT THE STATE
THROUGH COVID.
NO WONDER SO MANY FAMILIES LEFT
ILLINOIS PUBLIC SCHOOLS.
MEANWHILE, ARIZONIANS HAVE A
CHANCE TO ELECT KARI LAKE AS
THEIR GOVERNOR, DYNAMIC AND BOLD
AND VOWING TO TACKLE THE BORDER
AND CRIME PROBLEMS.
BUT HER DEMOCRAT CHALLENGER
KATIE HOBBS, OH, MY, SHE'S
HORRIBLE IN EVERY WAY.
>> I'VE CONTINUED TO MEET WITH
COMMUNITY LEADERS, AND FOCUS ON
HOW WE CANNOT JUST BUILD A
CAMPAIGN THAT'S INCLUSIVE, BUT
MAKE SURE THAT OUR GOVERNMENT AT
EVERY LEVEL OF THE
ADMINISTRATION, REFLECTS THE
DIVERSITY OF THE STATE OF
ARIZONA.
>> Laura: OH, MY GOODNESS, SHE'S
AS DEADLY BORING AND UNINSPIRING
BUT, WELL, NO MORE SAID THAN
DEMOCRAT SENATOR MAGGIE HASSAN
IN NEW HAMPSHIRE WHO DEBATED
BOLDEN THIS WEEK.
INSTEAD OF FOCUSING ON THE FACT
THAT WE COULD HAVE HEATING OIL
RATIONING THIS WINTER, SHE WENT
BACK TO 2020.
>> HERE'S THE THING ABOUT
ELECTION DENIERS, RIGHT?
HE IS WORKING AND HAS BEEN
WORKING TO CONCEAL HOW EXTREME
HE IS.
DON BOLDUC CAN IGNORE WHERE MORE
GRANT IT STATERS ARE ON THOSE
ISSUES I JUST TALKED ABOUT,
RIGHT, BECAUSE HE THINKS HE
DOESN'T NEED TO ACCEPT ELECTION
RESULTS.
>> Laura: FIRST OF ALL, STOP
SAYING RIGHT.
OH, MY GOSH, PAINFUL.
AND THEN IN A CATEGORY BY
HERSELF IS OREGON'S LEFT WING
LOAN TINA KOTEK WHO'S RUNNING
FOR GOVERNOR THERE.
>> PORTLAND IN PARTICULAR IN AD
TO MAKING MEASURE 110 WORK WE
NEED A METH STABILIZATION CENTER
IN PORTLAND.
WE NEED A PLACE FOR COPS TO TAKE
FOLKS, NOT THE EMERGENCY
DEPARTMENTS, WHEN THEY ARE IN A
MET-RELATED PSYCHOSIS.
>> Laura: METH STABILIZATION
CENTERS.
PORT LAN NEEDS LAW AND ORDER NOT
WAYS TO MAKE DRUG USE MORE
COMFORTABLE FOR PEOPLE.
COME ON TINA.
THEY'RE SO WORRIED ABOUT THE
SEAT THEY SENT CHIEF PRINCESS
RUNNING SCARED E LIZ BETH WARN
OUT THERE TO THE TROOPS THERE.
BUT SHE SCANT SPIN IT WARNING
OREGON IS DANGEROUSLY CLOSE TO
FLIPPING RED FOR THE FIRST TIME
IN 40 YEARS.
NOW POCAHONTAS AND HER TRIBE
SHOULD BE NERVOUS BECAUSE
KOTEK'S CHALLENGER CHRISTINE
DRAZEN IS JUST WHAT THE STATE
NEEDS, CALM, COOL, AND TOUGH ON
CRIME.
>> TINA KOTEK IS THE ORIGINAL
DEFUND THE POLICE CANDIDATE.
SHE DID NOT SUPPORT POLICE, EVEN
WHEN RIOTERS WERE ATTACKING A
POLICE STATION.
IT'S STUNNING TO ME THAT SHE
WOULD TALK NOW LIKE SHE SUPPORTS
LAW ENFORCEMENT.
>> Laura: OF COURSE SHE DOESN'T.
AND, LOOK, DRAZEN IS A NOTICE
NONSENSE REPUBLICAN.
MAYBE NOT AS CONSERVATIVE AS I'D
LIKE BUT THIS IS AFTER ALL THE
PACIFIC NORTHWEST, GOT TO BE
REALISTIC.
AGAIN, WHICH PARTY HERE HAS THE
BAD CANDIDATES AGAIN?
NOW, AS FOR THAT GEORGIA
MATCH-UP BETWEEN LIBERAL RAFAEL
WARNOCK AND HERSCHEL WALKER, THE
DEMOCRATS MAY WISH THEY HADN'T
REVVED UP THE SMEAR MACHINE,
BECAUSE IF WALKER DOESN'T FLINCH
AND IF THE HITS KEEP COMING AND
HE KEEPS GOING AND THEN HE GOES
ON TO WIN, HE'LL BE A SOLID VOTE
FOR SENSIBLE MEASURES SUCH AS
CLOSING THE SOUTHERN BORDER AND
OPENING NEW OIL AND GAS PIPE
LINES.
NOW, WITH THE NASTINESS, ALL OF
IT THROWN AT HIM, WALKER WILL BE
BATTLE TESTED FOR WHAT THE SWAMP
WILL BRING HIM.
AND LAST BUT NOT LEAST, AND I
COULD GO ON AND ON, LET'S NOT
FORGET THE WORST OF THEM ALL,
UNCLE JOHN FETTERMAN IN AN.
>> HI.
GOOD NIGHT EVERYBODY.
I DO SUPPORT FRACKING, AND I
DON'T, I DON'T -- I SUPPORT
FRACKING AND I STAND AND I
SUPPORT FRACKING.
I DON'T EVER RECALL IN THE
STATUE OF LIBERTY DID THEY EVER
SAY, YOU KNOW, TAKE OUR TIRED,
HUDDLED MASSES AND PUT THEM ON A
BUS.
THAT'S LIKE, YOU KNOW, HE GOT
HIS PENNSYLVANIA HOUSE FROM HIS
OWN A DOLLAR.
THAT'S TYPICAL.
>> Laura: FETTERMAN'S DEBATE
PERFORMANCE WAS THE WORST IN
MODERN AMERICAN HISTORY NO DOUBT
ABOUT THAT.
SO THIS LEAVES DEMOCRATS IN A
HUGE BIND.
THEY'RE LEFT TRYING TO DO THE
WORST KIND OF SPIN.
>> THE PRESIDENT HAS FOUND HIM
TO BE IMPRESSIVE, INCREDIBLY
BRIGHT AND TALENTED PERSON WHO'S
JUST AS CAPABLE, AS ALWAYS, TO
CARRY OUT HIS OFFICE, THE DUTIES
OF HIS OFFICE, AND HAS GREAT
ABILITY AND HEART FELT CONCERN
FOR THE PEOPLE OF THE
COMMONWEALTH.
>> WHAT I SAW LAST NIGHT, WHEN I
SAW JOHN FETTERMAN I THINK OF
COURAGE.
THIS GUY STOOD UP LAST NIGHT,
GOD BLESS JOHN FETTERMAN.
>> Laura: DO THE VOTERS OF
PENNSYLVANIA REALLY APPRECIATE
WHAT HAPPENED ON WEDNESDAY?
NOW, IT WAS AN INSULT TO THEM
WHAT HAPPENED TO THEM ON
WEDNESDAY.
NOW, GOD BLESS EVERYBODY, BUT
THAT'S NOT WHAT THE PENNSYLVANIA
VOTERS NEED.
THEY ONLY GET TO SEND TWO
SENATORS TO PENNSYLVANIA AND
THIS IS THE ONE THE DEMOCRATS
CHOSE AS THE BEST IN THE STATE
TO RUN.
REALLY?
AND THE SAME PEOPLE WHO LIED
ABOUT FETTERMAN'S CONDITION WERE
TRYING TO TELL US THAT DR. OZ IS
SUPPOSEDLY THE BAD CANDIDATE IN
THIS MATCH-UP.
A FORMER HEART SURGEON AND AN
ENTREPRENEUR FROM AN IMMIGRANT
FAMILY WHO ACHIEVED THE AMERICAN
DREAM, THAT'S THE BAD CANDIDATE?
YEAH, NICE TRY.
THE RACE IS SO DIRE THERE THAT
OBAMA IS SWOOPING IN.
>> SWOOPING INTO WESTERN PA TO
TRY TO DO THE RESCUE ATTEMPT.
AND THEY'RE SO FREAKED OUT THAT
EVEN BIDEN AND KAMALA ARE
PAIRING TOGETHER AT A RARE RALLY
APPEARANCE FOR FETTERMAN.
NOW THAT IS TRULY DESPERATE.
NOW HERE'S THE REALITY.
WE SHOULDN'T JUDGE CANDIDATES BY
WHETHER THE PRESS LIKES THEM OR
WHETHER BIG BUSINESS LIKES THEM
OR WHETHER THEY WILL GO WITH THE
FLOW IN DC.
WE SHOULD JUDGE THEM ON WHETHER
THEY'LL FIGHT FOR THE NATIONAL
INTERESTS AND STAND UP FOR THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE.
NOW, THIS YEAR, ALL OVER THE
COUNTRY, REPUBLICAN VOTERS CHOSE
TALENTED, SELF-MADE MEN AND
WOMEN WHO THINK FOR THEMSELVES
AND WHO WILL FIGHT FOR YOU.
THE DEMOCRATS, THEY MOSTLY
NOMINATED ESTABLISHMENT HACKS
WHO WILL DO WHATEVER PELOSI AND
SCHUMER TELL THEM TO DO.
AND WHEN A SMART, INDEPENDENT
THINKER GOES UP AGAINST SOMEONE
WHO JUST DOES WHAT THE HANDLERS
TELL THEM, EVEN THE BIAS PRESS
CAN'T HELP BUT RECOGNIZE THE
DIFFERENCE IN QUALITY.
WE HAVE BETTER CANDIDATES, MUCH
BETTER.